so there's a whole field of artificial
life
i don't know if you're connected to this
field if you uh pay attention
is do you think about this kind of thing
is there impressive demonstration to you
of artificial life do you think of
the agents that you work with in the
evolutionary competition
perspective as life and
where do you think this is headed like
is there interesting systems that will
be creating more and more
that uh make us redefine maybe rethink
about the nature of life different
levels of
definition and goals there then i mean
at some level artificial life
can be considered multi-agent systems
that build a society that again achieves
a goal
and it might be robots that go into a
building and clean it up or
or after an earthquake or something you
can think of that as an artificial life
problem
in some sense um or you can really think
of it
artificial life as a simulation of life
and a tool to understand what life is
and how life evolved in
earth and like i said in an artificial
life conference there are
branches of that conference sessions are
people who really worry about
molecular designs and and the start of
life like the
like i said primordial soup where
eventually you get something
self-replicating
and they're really trying to build that
um so it's a whole range of
of uh of topics um
and i think that artificial life is a
great tool
uh to understand life and there are
questions like
sustainability um species we're losing
species
uh how bad is it is it natural
uh is there a tipping point um
and where are we going i mean like the
hyena evolution we may have
understood that there's a pivotal point
in their evolution
they discovered cooperation and
coordination um
you know artificial light simulations
can identify that and
uh maybe encourage things like that um
so
and and also societies can be seen as a
form of life itself i mean we're not
talking about biological evolution
of evolution of societies maybe some of
the same
phenomena emerging in that uh domain and
unders
and having artificial life simulations
and understanding could help us
build better societies yeah and thinking
from a
meme perspective of of uh from
richard dawkins that
maybe the organism's ideas of the
organisms not the humans
in these societies that from
it's almost like reframing what is
exactly evolving
maybe the interesting the humans aren't
the interesting thing is the contents of
our minds is the interesting thing and
that's what's multiplying
and that's actually multiplying and
evolving in a much faster time scale
and that maybe has more power on the
trajectory of life on earth than
does biological evolution yes the
evolution of these ideas yes
and it's fascinating like i said before
that
we can keep up somehow biologically yeah
we are
people to a point where we can keep up
with this meme evolution
literature you know internet um we
understand
dna and we understand fundamental
particles we didn't start that way i
mean thousand years ago
and we haven't evolved biologically very
much but somehow our minds are able to
uh extend and therefore ai can be seen
also as
one such step that we created and it's
our tool
uh and it's part of that meme evolution
that that we create
even if our biological evolution does
not progress as fast
and us humans might only be able to
understand so much we're keeping up
so far or we think we're keeping up so
far but we might need ai systems to
understand
maybe like the physics of the universe
is operating
like a string theory maybe it's
operating in much higher
dimensions maybe we're totally because
of our cognitive
limitations they're not able to truly
internalize
the way this world works and so our lim
we're running up against the limitation
of
our own minds and we have to create
these next level
organisms like ai systems that would be
able to understand much
deeper like really understand what it
means to live in a
uh multi-dimensional world that's
outside of the four dimensions the three
of space and
translation and and generally we can
deal with the world even if you don't
understand all the details we can use
computers
yes even though we don't most of us
don't know all the
structures underneath or drive a car i
mean there are many components
especially new cars that you don't quite
fully know but you have the interface
you have an abstraction of it
that allows you to operate it and
utilize it and i think that that's
that's perfectly adequate and we can
build on it and ai can be
play a similar role
you